- And me getting my Oscar.
And I wanna thank Sophie Turner,
'cause she's the best thing
that ever happened to me.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- [woman in blue] We're gonna
have you hold up this picture
of Leonardo DiCaprio, and
put it next to your face,
and I'm gonna swap your faces.
- (laughing) Okay.
- [woman in blue] You look fabulous,
do you feel good about it?
- Oh, I feel so good.
- [woman] Obviously you
know Leo DiCaprio very well.
- Yes.
- Do you wanna swap faces?
Hold this for a second, and we'll do it.
- Sure, oh m god.
This is kind of unholy.
My acceptance speech?
I probably thank all Native Americans,
including that one handsome
one named Forrest Goodluck.
- [woman in blue] So there's
a filter that just came out,
like swap-your-face filter.
- I love that filter!
- You're about to do it with Leo.
- Oh my gosh.
I really wanna thank the bear,
'cause he was a really
big part in my Oscar.
(laughing)
Oh my god, that's so,
look at, oh no that's terrible.
(laughing)
- [woman in blue] Isn't that amazing?
Isn't that crazy? (laughing)
So basically you just hold it
next to your face really close.
- What, am I supposed to be talking?
Oh you're filming?
Leo, what do you think
of your chances tonight?
100%, dude, easy.
It's in the bag.
I would say, "Go to change.org/era,
"and get women equal rights in America."
- Have you guys done this face swap?
- Yes, yes, I have it.
(upbeat music)
- Thanks to everybody, thanks to director,
Thanks to the Hawk!
Yeah, the Hawk in the movie, The Revenant.
He's a great guy.
(laughing)
- Oh my god, with Leo
with a (voice fades out).
(upbeat instrumental music)